uh well my first robbery was a setup
but after i got good at robberies i
would get an area
and i would know the area and i would
literally case 150 jewelry stores to
make sure i got the right one
in an area and it usually took case of
means make sure the right
just to give you an idea uh you don't
just rob a jewel store
i would know where the sun rises and
sets so if there's glare in the window
they couldn't see in or people would be
blinded
so that was an important thing to get
away
how close it was to other uh places how
many people
i used to like to rob in plazas when
there was a publix
or a grocery store i don't know where
people are around the world
pathmark publix win dixie because the
more people going you can sit and watch
that story without looking
conspicuous so i would
uh make sure and and people are so
[ __ ] oblivious
they'd walk by and i'd be [ __ ] in the
middle of a robbery but again
i knew that the sun so they can't even
look in
did the jewelry store put display cases
that blocked
where i can look in you know they make
difference i do that now sometimes i
help jewelry stores
jewelry prevention you know to help not
get robbed
how is the back entrance can you get in
and out can i park a car there
uh where how what time are the people
coming what time is the mailman coming
do police ever come by the area uh what
time
every employee and what car they have
these are
all things that i would know before i
even did a jewish
wow and then know where the cameras were
where the buzzers were
did they have what they called they had
buzzes in their pocket that if they hit
the buzzer in a part an alarm would go
up
is the door have a lock on it i love
those
i like those really oh absolutely
because then nobody else is going to
come in they want me and i'm coming in
with a rolex watch and a suit and
they're going man this guy's got money
let him in but i i would get to know him
beforehand and
know where the jewelry was in the store
there's so much to it that's a whole
show
right but the uh uh when you
when you case a jewelry store
as a professional you know it's so crazy
people ask me to this day could you do
it
there isn't a [ __ ] question in my
mind i can rob a jewelry store tomorrow
and get away with it really i i see him
all the time
really all the time i could rob that
[ __ ] jewish store
no question because all the knowledge i
mean i've did so many
i've cased over a thousand jewelry
stores well over a thousand
and that means going in and out knowing
every [ __ ]
little detail i go into a jewelry store
now and it's like
[ __ ] sensory overload really i can
imagine
you know and i go oh man this guy could
be hit did you ever just walk into a
jewelry store and casually just looking
at watches
and that's kind of well i go i usually
go with somebody you know for some
reason
and because first of all they're the
biggest cons too
oh yeah [ __ ] biggest racket there is
and and i i remember one jewelry store
they
they were a lot i went to the gia
institute which is the gemological
institute of america just to know about
diamonds
so they can't rob me you know my fences
couldn't rob me
i used to go into a jewish store like i
didn't know what i was doing
and the [ __ ] owner would be [ __ ]
lying to me so [ __ ] bad i
one one guy was so bad i can't wait to
rob this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy is really bad he must
have [ __ ] stole more money than i
ever stole
from people you know there's a few
things i tell
tell your viewers here uh in is
the first thing you want to do is don't
don't ever go to a jewelry store that
doesn't have a 10 powered microscope on
the desk
10 powered microscope on the [ __ ]
counter where you can look at a diamond
the right way
okay uh there's certain things if they
don't tell you about
see everybody knows the four c's but
they don't know what the cut is that's
the most important part
not not a and i don't mean the cut is it
a round or a
marquee right hair shape i'm talking to
geometrics the
geometry how light reflects on diamonds
oh it makes them better where you can
get a really good cut diamond
and the light will reflect better so
it'll be a less
color diamond right but it'll be a
better diamond because it'll glow more
shine more or be more brilliant because
of the cut
and how it extracts light i love it when
they show you a diamond ago look at that
and it's under a [ __ ] light i'll make
a piece of [ __ ] glass
look good take a diamond and put it
under the table
when there's very little light and see
how it uh how it reacts
so when you would rob a jewelry store
did you like were you
picky of the [ __ ] that you took oh oh no
no i
wiped the whole thing you wiped off but
i didn't rob the store unless it had
certain things
oh okay like there was usually there
always would be a
loose box of diamonds now the box would
be about that big
like a card box you know like right
correct and it'd be all [ __ ] diamonds
and they're all loose right so there
could be a carrot
well they call it melee melee diamond i
forget the word is
melee melee no never heard that no maybe
i got that from the pond business i got
a friend who owns a bunch of pawn shops
[Laughter]
well yeah he's robbing people oh yeah
they're all in the caribbean too
oh god he's really wrong guy gets off a
boat
oh yeah yeah but so yeah so you
that those loose stones
are what i'm literally calculating that
thing in my head when he shows it to me
then i'm looking in the store and what i
have in display cases
watches i used to get rollick i loved
rolex's i used to get two thousand
dollars aurora it's the five thousand
dollar like presidential
right 000 everyone i robbed 50 of them
it's 100 grand
wow without blinking they wouldn't even
find okay put them in a bag
they used to give them away as presents
that's amazing man
but then but then the diamond so i'm
literally then you watch where they
don't put that box
a lot of times they don't put the box in
the safe goes to a back room
another safe a false floorboard
that's their money that's what i want i
want that because
i the first question i would ask i'm
looking for a ring maybe a little carry
you know first i had a whole line of
stick i'd say
oh i'm in the area i'm a contractor
i'm in the area and i shoot rolex gold
chain
nice diamond bracelets worth [ __ ]
twenty five thousand
and that's that's i'd say that guy i'd
say uh yeah i'm in the area i'm a
builder and i just
look and i'm married ten years now when
i first got married i got my wife a
little
little ring so i want to look at some
good rings he's saying oh [ __ ] i got
this guy he's you know you got money
he's in the area and he i said
uh well what do you have anything i want
to maybe have it set the only loose
stone
oh hold on after these seas you know
they break out that box
i'd say well let me start at the one
carat maybe
i'll see how small it looks and i'm
watching where he picks it out of that
box
so if he picks it over here okay
he shows it to me i look at it and all
these bullshitting me with the price and
the reins
then he go and i go um let's make it a
little bigger if he goes this way
then i know these are all [ __ ] but if he
goes the other way and he only goes
up a little bit then i know all those
are bigger than 2k
um sorry [ __ ] i'm my brain is already
calculating that [ __ ] box oh there's
a quarter million
maya quarter million where you putting
that
and my brain is working so differently
as a criminal
then uh like your brain would work right
right you're not looking to say oh i can
rob
i mean it was just it was like holy [ __ ]
so how did it all go wrong for you what
was like the final one the fbi were
great [ __ ]
oh really they caught me the fbi well
the last
store robbery the guy got out we think
a robbery happened we didn't notice they
robbed an air conditioner off the unit
it was a plasma
yeah anyway so some lady heard some
commotion came up to the window and
looked in the window and saw
us then we knew we had to go go go go
yeah and we had plans everything was
planned
but the guy the owner got out of his
flex cuffs
and i already stole six guns out of him
his flex cuff you know like
uh the wire cuffs you know okay yeah
electrical wire things
okay he got out of him and it was
another gun the [ __ ] was a gun nut
and he started we're running at the
office on gunshots
and the glass is breaking in front of it
we're running out and there's glass he's
shooting at us
so listen we get now it's already
planned
i had every detail planned i get in the
car
and he levels the gun right at my
[ __ ] head
in the windshield because the car was
pulled in straight
i duck as i duck the bullet goes
through the windshield gets the top of
my head
and i didn't even feel it but then i see
blood coming down my face but
another bullet he shots twice or that
bullet
my brother ducked and it went in his
back
into his arm it's still in his arms to
this day
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] we showed it online
anyway and he goes i'm hit i'm here i go
yeah and i didn't even know i had the
blood trickle down my until i looked in
the mirror
i'll drop you off the hospice no [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that
we went back to brooklyn where this is
in pennsylvania
so we went back to brooklyn and in
brooklyn we
[ __ ] had an apartment you know like
the mob's this
above the [ __ ] bar and we had [ __ ]
people that changed the glass out of the
car we [ __ ] patched my brother up we
cleaned me up everything was good
everything was all good
and after we did that got him back but
we little did we know the fbi
flooded the area see i didn't know the
fbi was on me that big oh they're
already on you huh yeah
for six years the guy was on me matt
mullen six [ __ ] years
good guy too nice guy yeah yeah no no
hard feelings
and he [ __ ] they flooded the area
they got me and they ended up getting
footage they even had footage of me
buying a cup of wild
a [ __ ] coffee at a wawa store
that's how much they they confiscated
every camera within
like a mile or two miles of that [ __ ]
area you know every gas station i mighta
went to
every [ __ ] thing they went to every
jewelry store that i might have cased
and they got a lady go oh there was a
nice guy in here
and i got his plate number because i was
gonna sell him a ring i didn't even rob
that store
and then they and they still didn't have
me because i had the guy
work for me was a fat fat guy yeah who's
350 pounds
yeah i wasn't 350. so [ __ ]
that's not him but i was a co-driver and
then they looked my name
up and i was organized crime i already
got pinched for
uh having 35 000 cash in my glove
compartment and six grams of coke
that's when they got you well no that
was another time okay oh my god
i